how about the southpointe 400 is about a
month away now at the las vegas motor
speedway the bush brothers are hoping to
make some noise on their home track
again this year ron futrell is live
tonight at southpointe with the
defending champion from 2020 and a
former nascar champion that is kurt
buschron the fun never ends with kurt
busch
it does not we got kurt bush with us
live here chris and kurt okay let's go
back a little bit i'm thinking 22 years
almost 750 races i remember you racing
legends cars out of
the ball ring not that long ago
it's been amazing uh when my dad put me
in his race car when i first started out
i was like i don't know what i'm doing
and then the second race i won
and then third fourth fifth race i
wrecked and mom's like all right we're
gonna pull the plug we're gonna go back
to the little league baseball
and my dad says okay just go out there
and finish tenth for me
what does that mean like we're here
we're here
yeah we're here to win dad and so when i
finished 10th and i paid 20 bucks he
goes did you understand money there i'm
like oh
you can you can make money at this deal
no it's been fun status and mom and
grandma everybody helped out so much
defending champ at the south point of
course and you're going to have you're
going to have fans this year you didn't
have it last year when you won so that's
got to be exciting for you huh
i feel like everybody was there with me
but they weren't and just having friends
family relationships and everybody back
at track that's what family and nascar
is all about and so it's like they were
there but not but yet i've gotten to
celebrate for the last 300 and some odd
days leading up to the south point 400
and brendan and michael gong everybody
here at south point has made it feel
like family when i won here at vegas saw
you at allegiance stadium today what do
you think of that place not bad huh
that's incredible i mean if that doesn't
make you want to play football and win
championships then then you got to be
somewhere else coach gruden carr the
whole gang with the raiders that's a
different element
vegas showed up with the las vegas motor
speedway late 90s this is 2020 and at
legion stadium now it's the show for
sports okay they're telling me to wrap
it you want to here take the mic toss it
back to chris for me
kurt busch nascar champions back to you
chris in the studio all right there he
is he's really one of the friends of
channel 8 here like to thank curt and
ron we'll have much more with kurt bush
tonight 11 o'clock that southpoint 400
is the same day the raiders are hosting
the dolphins and the vegas golden
knights are hosting the san jose sharks
so
boy busy busy day brian denise and the
fun never stops here last